the extra-large is available in cayenne
Moss and aubergine snack and the plum
black I really want plum do you think
Moss is pretty you know I don't know
lady why don't you just pick a color
please Steve Johnson he never struck me
as the kind of guy who'd go get small
Wow so the decision to downsize thing
takes the pressure right off especially
money pressure we live like kings well
time to move we're really strapped you
want my advice
Lee's your lands where you want to be in
leisure Lane your hundred thousand
dollars translates to twelve million
dollars Wow
I just got another diamond bracelet
pretty nifty huh okay let's go for it
nervous little the day you will undergo
the permanent and irreversible procedure
known as downsizing
granny you've got a call oh don't be mad
at me please don't be mad I can't leave
my family I can't leave my friends I'm
sorry Paul I should have been thinking
more about myself thinking about
yourself how do I be just all as large
as you can please
I noticed you put a pretty big dent
anyone's self-esteem but downsizing is
about hitting the reset button start all
over I have allergies
wait wait I'm gonna take off my world is
filled with things to see
that one is really sick you'll help her
these are the people that we should be
helping
[Music]
something Betty beeps something
top-secret why did I downsize so that I
could be here right now I finally have a
chance to do something that matters I
[Music]
think we're in the normal world then
something happens oh my god when you
realize we're not
[Music]
you